[Music]
howdy-ho reject nation I'm Greg Alba
what's your name hi I'm Paula Deming
Paula Deming is here with us today you
can find her on the fan Theory TV
channel on NBC on YouTube on YouTube for
this series we watch who where I watched
Doctor Who for the first time and react
to it so live vicariously through me and
my joy of watching Doctor Who for the
very first time wow that was very
professional yeah it's my job if you're
in the video game let's plays I do story
base stuff in the game so come and find
me there it's under my name Paula Demi
yourself promote good job I can't even
talk about myself that I'm talking about
my looks
[Music]
let's watch the yeah that's called from
Newport movies caught reusing footage
from other movies did you know there's a
thing in Disney movies if you watch
classic Disney movies they reuse a lot
of animation so there's stuff from Snow
White
they reuse in really like the Robin Hood
movie like so a lot of old animation is
just ruined I'm hoping to see some
things like that but in a modern way and
not Disney in this video interesting I
think I did see Pinocchio in Fox in the
hound and I both I believe there there
was a penis castle in the Little Mermaid
well in the original it you can't that's
not on the covers now the DVD if you buy
it now I have that cover and it's also
$90 in the marriage scene they fixed
that now too so we made my mom keep our
VHS copy of it
so that we could have a record of the
thing that Disney has tried to erase but
we all know what happened
I reuse that footage all the time for
videos of my girlfriend and I there's
the first time follows meeting me see a
tweet from Paulo later oh we all know
Hollywood loves to recycle ideas of
course while we don't often realize that
Studios sometimes even reuse footage
from old installments in the same
franchise or from completely unrelated
movies let's take a look back at some of
the most surprising examples of film
matters recycling parts from another
movie life and spider-man 3 using stock
footage in multiple movies is nothing
new but we received an unexpected
reminder of that when someone discovered
that a scene in a TV spot for the 2017
sci-fi film life is actually taken
straight out of Sam Raimi's spider-man 3
the scene in question appears about 34
minutes into spider-man 3 with people
looking up at gwen stacy hanging off the
edge of a building shortly before
spiderman comes and rescues her
that is not gonna hurt you oh yeah an
altered version of the scene appeared
around the 26 second mark in a TV spot
for life
Oh didn't make it into the final cut
it's just beer awful okay news for the
commercial since they're the studio that
produced and distributed both spider-man
during them one of the villains in
spider-man 3 fans of the superhero
franchise have begun to speculate a
possible connection between the two
films what if the organism and life is
actually the Venom symbiote that's a
twist worthy of M night Shyamalan the
most amazing swarmers recycling doesn't
bother Michael Bay he's got theory using
several scenes from some of his older
films and often does it so seamlessly
that it's difficult to tell that's hard
one of the more recent editing spotted
in Transformers Dark of the Moon okay
the third Transformers movie features a
car chase scene on a freeway which
includes a portion of another car chase
sequence Bay has previously filmed for
his 2005 release the island instead of
having bounty hunters chasing the
inclusion of the men due to the studio
wants into language liability the god of
the moon set was particularly
accident-prone the first major accident
due to a snapped steel cable left an
extra permanently brain damaged and
partially paralyzed just a second
accident occurred a month later when the
Camaro that portrays bumblebee collided
with a police SUV injuring both drivers
at that point someone may have gotten
the bright idea to just use a car chases
into a summer blockbuster movie based on
a toy line would have been enough to put
any studio on edge so it's
understandable that when Michael Bay was
filming the original transformers he cut
corners by reusing a piece of footage of
an aircraft carrier from Pearl Harbor
while making harbor in 2000 they used
the USS Lexington to represent the USS
Hornet as well as a Japanese carrier
instead of shooting another scene using
one of the Navy's carriers for
Transformers they just recycled is
definitely cheaper than a ring
shave off some well when one movie uses
footage from another they're usually
similar in some way but there's nothing
even remotely alike between Austin
Powers The Spy Who shagged me and Apollo
13 these two films ordinarily wouldn't
find their titles uttered in the same
sentence
were it not for one particular scene in
Austin Powers mini-me escapes with God
away in the movie to capture him Austin
and Felicity hitch a ride on at eleven
along with one of the NASA's astronauts
and if the whole sequence seems out of
place that's because it is an eagle-eyed
viewer notice that it was taken right
out of Apollo 13 it was a sequence
created by Academy award-winning visual
effects designer Robert legato
who received an Oscar nomination for Wow
in some cases filmmakers are onto
battery using old footage as was the
case with Lucas films first Star Wars
anthology film in the original Star Wars
the Rebel Alliance destroyed the Death
Star after obtaining the Space Station's
blueprints and discovering its fatal
design flaw in open exhaust port the
reason for the vulnerable opening as
well as the way the rebels obtained the
Death Star plans in the first place
became the basis for road 1 drove one
story unfolds days before the events of
a new hope and ends mere moments before
the original film begins to give the
impression that the film is a prequel to
Episode four director Gareth Edwards
worked with IOL to digitally recreate
Peter Cushing and Carrie Fisher's
likenesses but they didn't stop there
the filmmakers also brought back the
original golden-red leaders played by
Angus McGinnis and drew him Lee
respectively Edwards was offered access
to the Lucasfilm fault so he found old
and archived footage from a new hope for
the duo and has even recorded new
dialogue specifically for row of one
still it was a gamble skeptical about
using the old footage at first but when
the two rebel leaders appeared on-screen
during Road ones premiere the audience
cheer that's a good actually I'm pretty
sure it has to do with I think it's read
one and not last a tie but um for a new
hope they actually shot some female
x-wing pilots okay but they cut from the
movie they
we're not in it okay but they took some
of that old footage if they hadn't used
and recut it in to I just want that now
there are female x-wing pilots in the
movie and so there was all this old
footage they didn't use but then they
cut into this movie oh-ho nice yeah I
thought that was really cool oh so it
wasn't like that footage didn't appear
in a new hope it was like least the ones
with the women
it didn't some of this stuff that he was
talking about well why would it why
would you have women in tactical
military positions what is the funniest
thing I've heard in a while and we're
lucky I'm even capable of sitting in
Furman camera and talking about I agree
this is the first time I met Paula
making sexist joke there's a version
[Laughter]
I've actually heard about that like life
people thinking that the symbiote is
what's going on in the movie life I've
heard that theory it's one thing to take
something like to me the rocket ship
moment from Austin Powers in Apollo 13
is not really a huge deal other than the
fact like what you brought up like that
guy probably should have gotten paid for
taking that shot no maybe the studio was
like well part of the deal is we own
this asset now we paid you for the hours
yeah we can reuse it like that I think
that's not a big deal because I'm like
it's Austin Powers it's they're going in
a rocket it's dr. evil and mini-me like
in fact it's kind of funnier than it's
Apollo 13 also because they're meant to
be an Apollo 13 going up yeah yeah
exactly but but to use footage of the
same people from spider-man
like that's just incredibly distracting
now when I see this imagery I'm just
imagining okay so they're in the Edit
Bay and they're watching the latest cut
and they're like oh we just need another
reaction shot they're like we don't we
don't have it we didn't shoot it on the
day and they're like okay well we can't
afford to do reshoots now so and then
some forces and editors just coke yeah
but this very famous moment in
spider-man 3 right here that is so sad
that they would from this angle looks
like they're like well to make it look a
little different let's cut out some
other people diversity let's keep the
black girl in the background here even
though we're mainly focused on the white
guy
let's like punch up his eyes a little
bit barely any different I mean but
Michael Bay movies all look recycled so
all the Transformers feel like the
action scenes specifically like well for
all I know I probably could have all
just been takes that word used or
recycled because beyond the Transformers
films a lot of his action films already
looked similar to the action sequences
in transformers and the fact there's not
giant robots there but as demonstrated
here on this freeway chase scene yeah
exact same thing just something
different falling on the cost of
different CGI insert yes I didn't
realize that they had so many accidents
on set for that movie that is really
kind of upsetting yeah especially the
fact there wasn't that public of no I
mean I'm sure it was made public but not
to the point where it was you know yeah
there's an extra who cares yeah yeah
could have at least been a stunt person
who died transformers I'm just expecting
to like sit around from us today and get
like lunch yeah I think you yell that
Michael Bay for doing something wrong
yeah although I gotta say I mean with
all those accidents going on that is the
one case where I'm like yeah maybe you
should just recycle some footage if
people are gonna keep dying either said
yeah are just like fully CG that sure
just green-screen the cars in there why
go through all the trouble yeah I mean
reusing certain establishing shots
doesn't really bother me like Pearl
Harbor and transform with it it is the
exact same shot but again like you would
never without someone pointing it out
like the fact that anyone even noticed
it to begin with is impressive to me
yeah maybe they just happen to have a
movie night where they were doing a
double feature and they watch the
two movies back today women put down the
joint let's look at this again this is a
movie that probably most people haven't
seen Avengers infinity before I used to
watch a lot of Hong Kong cinema when I
was a kid and there's this Jackie Chan
movie called fearless hyena which is one
of the movies that capitals at him to
stardom in Hong Kong and then they made
a movie called fearless hyena to where
they barely shot it so what they did was
they reused so much footage from the
first one I watched it and I was like
wildly confuse I did not know this fact
going in wait a minute the exact same
movie but literally it's not just like
the same plot they're the exact same
scenes but then when I read Jackie
Chan's autobiography because this is
before the internet oh there oh okay
[ __ ] that's why I was so confused yeah
when I read something I was reading
books now I do is read social media post
sad times are ahead of us but I don't
know this is an interesting videos
fascinating look at certain scenes the
same way ever again now I'm just I won't
trust anything I won't trust anything in
any who knows what this was originally
from it's funny how like Studios are
constantly recycling story ideas like
all the time yeah and then even Disney
with their live-action movies or just
the animated movies and to see this is
like oh man we handed out a path or
we're literally just gonna recycle just
because when you see trailers were like
a big thing that happens with the Marvel
movies especially the infinity war one
was because so much of it was CGI they
were able to completely put in different
things so that way they don't spoil the
movie
and I'm like we're on that path where
you can manipulate trailers to that
degree I'm pretty soon that'll be
infused in movies yeah so alright
interesting yeah did you know about any
of this stuff that's how you engage with
an audience that's where you call
engagement hey comment below there's
something that you already knew about or
something was surprising or maybe
there's something that wasn't in this
video that you know like tell us about
it I might be interested to see I want
to comment so bad you can I can't it's
not uploaded yet as we're speaking this
but it will be and then you can come in
and then we can engage helps videos get
a better algorithm performance we just
want a better algorithm black lives
matter too and hashtag me too but more
importantly we need more views on this
video subscribe to the region's
notification take it away follow come
check out fan berry TV YouTube channel
for my series we watch who watch me
watch Doctor Who for the very first time
or come check out my twitch channel it's
under my name Paula Deming I do Let's
Plays a video games and maybe you'll
like that that was great Paul you were
okay I know you own this video see you
next time